[Music]
the first time i saw it i couldn't
believe it i mean it was like the fauna
was completely different than anything
i'd seen before
when you get
eight or ten species on a small pool
still coexisting and they're all shrimp
or crabs
it's like well how do they do that how
do they split up the resources how do
they share things and so they all have
their job
feeding they're filter feeding they're
taking particles out of the water
they're picking on all of the things
that they can feed on
so all these things that process organic
material especially leaf litter and
there's a lot of it every day and some
months an enormous amount and certainly
after hurricanes huge amounts of litter
coming in to feed the food whip and it
works and it's been really resilient
if you put out a trap in one of the ways
that we sample our shrimp and you pull
it up and you see hundreds literally
hunters in each trap people's eyes light
up and say oh my goodness you know like
that's a lot of shrimp yeah and they're
doing a lot of work
the kinds of places where the shrimp
like to be
are exactly the same places where the
people like to be
the reason that they like the same
places that are shrimp do is the shrimp
are keeping it clean
and they're sweeping off the sediment
from the bottom they're turning a lot of
that material into their own
bodies and that the shrimp are able to
use a lot of things that would otherwise
pile up and be kind of slimy and not
very attractive to swimmers and so all
that sweeping and all that movement that
they do
is really keeping things great for
recreation
[Music]
and these shrimp do clean up the water
they're filter feeding out a lot of
organic material and turning it into
shrimp which turns into fish food and
various other kind of things within the
food web and they're working 24 hours a
day seven days a week at no cost to
puerto rico
in order for this system to work in the
mountains and for water quality to be
available and clean to the public
outside the forest outside the mountains
we really have to have connectivity we
have to have a really good way for
shrimp to migrate upstream and
downstream same with the fishes same
with the snails
when you start planting you know where
do you divert the water and do you have
a dam in the channel or a
reservoir off channel those are
important decisions for maintaining
these species
so we're hoping that more and more
people appreciate what is living in the
river and start to think about well how
can we keep it that way
because it does provide a lot of
important ecosystem services as we call
them
[Music]
you